remind some people that i am recently
divorced yes
hi everybody a lot of people say fantasy
protagonists are just like uh normal
book protagonists that's not true
fantasy protagonists are very different
type of people and here's how that's
fine that's fine how to write a fantasy
protagonist in and 67 list number a your
fantasy protagonist must come from a
small village this is
this is a tried and true method in faith
they can be they can be tall or they can
be
taller make sure to emphasize that
they're really tall point number
second they need a goal every character
in your book should have a goal unless
they're
pippin or samwise point next point your
character's got to get
power over over the course of the of the
book they they should be able to
murder anybody by snapping their fingers
there should be absolutely no stakes
when they're up against any sort of
challenge this is how fantasy
is just do it finally probably the most
important thing about your fantasy
protagonist is that they should have
a very simple name so that it's easy to
write and pronounce something like ron
or
pat that's hot in here right there
that's that's that should be like that
right
randall randall thor randall thor calden
sturm
stormy
[Music]